don't [ __ ] come in don't come in with
a boy hat Thanks
no it's not a nice hat you don't come in
here just are you rolling yes I'm holy
this [ __ ] guy comes in with a hat
sunglasses and a gallon of water
boots yeah these are my blunt stones
these are my blunt stones okay well
looks like we just started the new ad
campaign for blood ha ha these are my
blood stones these are my blood stones
you got chocolate in my blood stones you
got peanut butter in my bones
take it easy guys good new Jesus Christ
well Sasso is taking over for Brendan
Schaub today don't just throw things I'm
not ill they often give this time yes
[ __ ] table minutes don't bring up real
furniture has been on the air since
iPods exist rah do you know that iPods
don't exist anymore yeah I do
oh you don't yeah I do know don't do the
base thing well I'm not doing the bears
thing this is my natural resting voice I
don't know about that I'll tell you
something you um [ __ ] this doesn't
brother that's a water cooler sighs yeah
Tanner Brian okay ha ha everybody knows
we it's so annoying we that I drink a
lot of water what do you want today why
did you know what is I want for what do
you want
here's first question yes first question
oh [ __ ] do you think you are wearing a
hat like that that's actually a really
good question Brian yeah and I'd like to
just listen I want to talk directly to
your listeners okay they know that every
time you want to talk about me being in
Tempe this tomorrow Friday Saturday ruff
oh sure I'll tell them Tempe improv
Brian cow you said well I want to tell
them God Bryan Callen we'll be at the
Tempe improv it has 54 seats no it has a
lot more than that's a huge room I've
never been there well if you want to
come and open for me and be my [ __ ]
opener and get water and towels you can
but you know what I'm not not a stand-up
comedian Brian I'm a serious actor and
I'm a serious human being yeah well what
did you want to say you want to talk to
my listeners every time I come on the
podcast
it's your listeners know and I I love
visiting your listeners some of your
listeners have been our listeners on a
former podcast and it's an event it's a
reunion yeah and it's a time it's a time
for truth yeah so when you asked me who
the [ __ ] do you think you are and I know
you're doing a bit Brian I know you like
to do comedy yeah I do yeah yeah enjoy
it but I was serious about who the [ __ ]
do you think you are with that hat
that's right and I'm glad every once in
a while you are serious yeah I know my
friend Brian and every once in a while
he's serious I'll give you a serious
answer because again I owe it to your
audience yeah I know them they know me I
feel like we're friends okay and I'm
gonna answer you honestly good
William Sasso that's right Brian this is
who I am
now I'm will this is my little sass I
don't need you to be sincere and and do
some I don't know what you're doing here
these chairs are for enero hipot look
you're a giant you're a white Simone
yeah I know that but Brendon is a
[ __ ] world-class athlete yeah still
does he still run in sand and [ __ ] and
he's got fat plantar fasciitis on his
stupid foot cuz he's 250 pounds it's
actually 270 but he says Oh Brian just
[ __ ] does he do it or not okay man
okay okay aren't made for his bodyweight
okay but he also does a lot of ass run
right
yes [ __ ] squat and down just climb in
the stairs yeah he's gonna put on weight
and all I'm saying is yeah when he gets
stressed he puts on weight so I'll look
on saying I'm saying muscle yeah and his
muscular ass should have a problem
fitting in these chairs terrible chairs
yeah the best any weight like this cuz
my back doesn't like this is who I am
and it's I think especially on a podcast
yeah as as this podcast has grown and as
podcasting has grown I feel that it's
it's a medium that's matured
and it's matured I'm gonna stop you here
because I want a quiz
you're being very general and also very
annoying so what I'd like to say is this
what as I says this what what do you do
differently now that you didn't do a
year ago you you pretentious hat-wearing
son of a [ __ ]
it's lies it's a question and if you
start another sentence saying Brian I'm
gonna hurl my body at your face okay I
will [ __ ] knee you right in your
[ __ ] chops and if I do what if you if
you start sentences with Brian I don't
stop being tall I see how you're oh
you're kicking [ __ ] in your head well no
comma Brian see that one I started as
well all right well well Brian here's
the thing about that you asked a very
good question yeah and you said who the
hell do you think you are yeah and you
thought you were throwing me a [ __ ]
curve ball [ __ ] no because you
usually say we live is the 1960s [ __ ]
you know donkey kick in a [ __ ]
football through the uprights okay it's
a home run
it's not having me when you throw me a
curve I go yeah no because you go
usually you say I'm Will Sasso this time
you said I'm William Sasso yeah that's
my that's my god-given name yeah there's
a wonderful mother and father named but
I feel like it's a way of setting your
heel and now you're you're establishing
yourself and there's no compromise so
what the [ __ ] is different yeah I'm the
Yahoo that you were jumping around like
a [ __ ] like like like one of those
carnival barkers with no aim in sight
and just spin it around okay and bumping
in the walls which is what you do you
[ __ ] human slinky you human balloon
okay so so now apparently you're
different so what's different about you
well Brian I thought what it's like this
answer the question yeah and it's a
better question than your first question
okay and you know how to ask questions
hell you've got an incredible podcast to
your name that proves that yeah here's
here's what's different about me okay
and I'm looking right in the camera
right now even though you can't tell cuz
I'm wearing sunglasses
absolutely not of my friends the
difference though is this it's just it's
a simple one so there's no difference
there's no difference in me the
difference is I've accepted who this
[ __ ] is god dammit man you sound
like a bad Tony Robbins I mean what who
so you've gotten them the essence
you've got now you have yelled the onion
down to the - it's - it's sweet core
yeah that's right we're looking at a
sweet core onion right now you can do
you can eat a sweet corn onion one of
two ways yeah you can chow down on the
baby yeah the little tiny onion
yeah and find those sweet pickled onions
in the pickle aisle open it pickled and
now we've we've we've got downward got a
whole ass onion yeah you can do the work
instead yeah instead of just picking off
a baby like I hey you know what a
[ __ ] a little baby you oh you healed
you peeled they're after your eyes are
watering
yes sneezin and we get down to that core
in the middle yeah now we're at the
sweet core and that's who you are now
mm-hmm and that's you we're all with you
always weren't so we all are inside
Brian we're that sweet core you know and
I'm not afraid to show you my sweet
sweet tour so show me yours I'm not and
I'm not talking about that that sweet
brown balloon not that you're always on
about hey where's that award that I said
I want to [ __ ] you're an [ __ ]
is that it that's it right there yeah if
you don't and I'm glad that you'd have
it there because just like these narrow
ass chairs that's a narrow ass table
which would make it hard for you to have
a shoulder with squat stance for your
feet as you drop it down and get that
award in your whole [ __ ] and what put it
inside of you
I'm not putting a [ __ ] I know you're
not because I've accepted the award that
I gave you like a year ago or something
I didn't see that in my ass what are the
Oscars in the summer I don't know man
it's an outdoor event right I'm trying
to do a podcast and I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about you sound
high you do any [ __ ] yeah I do [ __ ] I
don't know about that
yeah [ __ ] like you're lying right now
well sure I do want to come how do you
do it like what is your like oh man what
are they called
do I get a multiple choice you're a
[ __ ] virgin bro yes so you're a high
voice you're a big high voice virgin so
what oh damn it when did you lose your
virginity jack oh around the average age
that most people do twenty-seven
something like that man I'm sorry about
that
I'm sorry did you cry oh yeah for days
dude days I just cried for days
um yeah cried and I apologized yeah to
the Lord you ever fart when you were
having sex when do I not fart when I'm
having aa ha ha ha I can't get the tip
of my shaft into a the sweet folds of a
woman's vagina with that because I need
energy food I need a complete protein
before I have sex usually amounts to a
nice bowl of red beans and rice ah jeez
I like and if you're eating beans some
rice you know you got to get some onions
in there oh god damn it some banana
slices why would you put banana slices
in there it makes sure if you it makes
your balls vibrate oh I've never heard
that all right you want to start this
podcast yeah yeah let's start recording
now do you feel like yeah American woman
is out right now what's that about with
Sienna Miller Christina Hendricks amy
madigan Aaron Voss we play husband and
wife he's so hungry to make out with her
hey man no it's not that kind of movie
no huh she had is she married yeah bring
her husband up she's so hot so Lee
Miller's husband no Christina Hendricks
I remember seeing her on an audition
before she was famous and and being mad
that my life I was so mad I couldn't
date her she was that hot I couldn't
believe how hot she every errand
who's that guy who's that [ __ ] guy I
got obviously I can I can date her who's
that guy what's that guy do Oh
she divorced her husband Oh No she's so
no no no no sure walking around single
jack
she was the best-looking woman I've ever
seen in my life I never forgot it
Oh I was like oh my lord you're the best
circle moment I've ever seen who the
[ __ ] is he
Hey Dude what's he do
I'm asking you are you talking to me
yeah so American woman is out in select
theaters now and you know probably go
further nationwide at some point so go
check that out Sienna Miller and I just
asked you a question in the Hendricks
what is herself I'm in it I'm in the
movie oh and then your good buddy uh joe
carnahan boss level Frank Grillo and joe
carnahan boss level oh yeah you're
coming out with that that's gonna I
can't wait for that and then after that
then what um well I just feel like you
can do a movie and it doesn't matter
what movie and it used to be you do a
movie and it was like a big deal and now
I feel like everybody does a movie and
no nobody talks about it I don't hear
about it and it just it's like we're
good friends and you don't know that I
have a movie up and you don't even have
to ask me back in the day would just be
on Entertainment Tonight
exactly I'm Mary Hart and a movie come
out that's right with people into it
yeah and now she talks and now it
doesn't matter like now I don't know now
- yeah it was like as good as the movie
is six people see it somehow yeah all
right well you know I'm picking up what
you're laying down you know and but
let's let's you know let's hope this
movie does I'll tweet about it better
that don't tweet about the [ __ ] what
is it
2011 I'll make it I'll make it a little
tweet about the moon I can make a bit
for it there you are all right there we
are hey our director Jake Scott in the
middle there that's at the Toronto
International Film Festival so we do
showbiz Brian and I yeah oh there I am
back there it looks like a heavy movie
yeah it's very heavy oh it is oh yeah
yeah yeah what's that about drugs no
it's about Sienna Miller who's well
there's Sienna Miller
I don't want to give away too wasn't she
the one married to Jude Law look dude I
don't [ __ ] read People magazine for
[ __ ] question
chin is nodding yeah yeah thanks I ended
up on this thing the Sienna Miller has a
daughter and some [ __ ] happens I just be
like hey Sienna Miller you're super hot
just marry a rich guy no sorry and a
movie you're really good go to the
Beverly Hills go to Clary good movie
executive oh no boo creamy Nobu or Wally
Wally's in Beverly Hills and just marry
one of those guys and then buy [ __ ] yeah
I said it what's uh Aaron what's Aaron
Aaron Paul Paul like he's all he's a
really sweet guy he is yeah he's a
really really nice guy here daliyah's
good friends of them yeah yeah Thalia
yeah he did I think they go way back
yeah yeah all friends he's not strange
kid oh they worked together on a movie
when Chris was like 19 or 20 or good
actor that guy yeah none of what he's a
good actor
yes he's written a strange bird no range
K no no no no no keep it down earth I'm
nice the only normal guy we had a good
time shooting that film out and suburban
been doing Loudermilk right now eating
eating a lot Indian food
yeah Loudermilk we're gonna go shoot
Loudermilk and then now we both have
sitcoms on the ABC network yeah we do
what's yours called what would you say
nothing Brian it's not schooled right so
and school is done well it's a kind of
oak tree is it schooled is schooled
spelled SCH ool ' no it's just not it no
it's a D crooked no it's not you up
against the D like have a cedar trying
to push it back into place no I'm not
those kind of crawls gonna go across
when watching Dancing with the Stars
don't [ __ ] does your short shorts
pushing a [ __ ] D no Dawg this better
tell you what you can push instead of a
[ __ ] thick D what you can push this
[ __ ] award
get into your [ __ ] why don't you get
it lubed up with some red beans and rice
parts and then push it up did your
[ __ ] disrespect me on my [ __ ]
podcast you know what I love about this
podcast so far it's probably about 30
minutes old yeah
you've gotten used to my hat I have I've
already so overwhelmingly ignored that
it doesn't matter what's with the hat
never seen you in one of those I just
thought I'd wear a hat oh I didn't know
you were in the rodeo but maybe you're a
cowgirl ah there is various krisily I've
got a part in um yeah I think these acts
night or movie and he's I said what are
you playing as a helicopter pilot
what and I go how do you do that and he
goes like this
he's in the Zack Snyder movie and he's
and he's like he's playing a helicopter
pilot and I go hey look uh I exactly and
I go what are you planning is I just go
like this get in if he's holding it like
it's a steering wheel cause he's never
helicopter yeah that's gonna be a
[ __ ] sharp learning curve yeah well
he I was feeling Julia doesn't do any of
that method work he doesn't go to
investigate or an interview helicopter
pilots are sit in a helicopter no the
first time he ever sits an aliquot there
will be when it's time to shoot he will
enter the hashtag helicopter pilot on
instagram and see what comes up and
that'll be the research and him to put
say get in like he's driving the [ __ ]
Cobra God in 1981 see if you can see if
you can name this this movie guys in a
helicopter
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo
shoo-shoo a machine gun shoot shoot and
then I'm gonna be the actor how can you
shoot women and children
you just gotta lay them a little less
don't lead him as much [ __ ] what a movie
[ __ ] full metal metal jacket okay god
what's this I'll do it again I am in a
world of [ __ ]
that's right incident offer you Vincent
D'Onofrio [ __ ] that movie's good it's a
really good [ __ ] incredible
long time god damn he just goes crazy
yep yeah you couldn't hack it you would
what would I do P you'd be look they're
sucking your thumb
I'm so scared oh [ __ ] he was awesome
guy anyway he was well American woman is
a movie like that if you like yeah it is
you like Full Metal Jacket
no you're like it's what are you gonna
talk you gonna talk [ __ ] about my move
now I movie I'm excited that you're in
all these movies you've kind of been
working a lot you've been gone huh
you've been gone yeah I've been gone I'm
back
I bought this happy last week speaking
of movies couple weeks ago in Idlewild
where our good pal Marshall Cooke was
shooting his film you're in it I'm in it
daliyah's in it yeah yeah job is in it
job is in it yeah Chad Kultgen was
almost in it but then he couldn't
because I I think Marshall cut the cut
the part he's and so yeah I was up there
in Idlewild shootin this movie and we
all got hats nice yeah congrats man
thanks Perry
do you like that so you ever ridden a
horse yeah I haven't have you ridden or
only for show business things yeah
yeah and I felt bad for the horse very
big horse yeah real big horse yeah
they're on credit lost a lot of weight
though not a lot of weight I'm trying to
lose a lot of weight okay trimmer I
thank you very much I'm playing the new
um what do you what
wait what were you gonna say now I don't
know I'm not supposed to talk about it
but it's another movie what is the movie
now no please nope no because I can
already tell please be honest now why
I'm on I'm an honest guy in my friend a
woman lie to you okay so who what are
you playing
yeah the new ah see I wasn't I've
already said too much
well I started now people couldn't
Google the old satchel mounting the new
your mouth went and you you were gonna
make a B sound yeah you're right I was
gonna say a B now maybe I can maybe
maybe you can just nod your head or
shake it now I want you to be careful
though cuz it's gonna there are people
listening and you don't want to lie now
right yeah but I'll are you telling me
if I'm nodding my head or shaking my
head yeah
so and feel like we're back in the
corner maybe you misspoke for a second
so not a big deal if you misspoke and
you can just say no right with this yeah
right were you gonna say that you're
relax relax
look relax were you gonna say that
you're playing the new Batman you can
say no oh hold on there's a small nod at
the end of the shakes oh no right no I'm
not putting nothing right mom okay good
you're nothing to me I'm playing someone
else and it's a lot of people think that
the part would have gone a different
direction a lot of people were thinking
perhaps it's time for a woman to play
the role yeah there's been talk of Idris
Elba playing the role but the role has
an actor in Africa yeah yeah in Africa
Brian just said but yeah that's an
Africa actor no yeah that's racist to
say an Africa that's not what we okay
who is that who's that friend ears it
comes by a plea plays poker with the
guys he's got his daughters on the
softball team with you oh the Mexico
don't do that right I don't know yeah
yeah I know I know you just you just we
talked about a movie that I'm in that's
a really serious drama yeah you talked
about the two women and now you want
yeah Merrigan wha mom no it's okay is
that the soundtrack that's the Lenny
Kravitz version no I'm not Batman Robert
Pattinson is Batman now
oh that suppose whatever that's a great
choice
Robert he'll do great that [ __ ] guy
is not Batman I'll beat him up right now
what are we talking about what go Brian
Callen wasn't available you got that guy
you got that guy with Bryan Callen a
fifty two-year-old not around I mean
he's a good-looking guy blaze he is
really good-looking kid he's got very
intense eyes yeah but but
I don't look at him as being Batman's a
tough [ __ ]
yeah but they gotta like read a read a
character for the younger generation huh
you know couldn't they have found a dude
who did one sport he played werewolf he
did he played vampire and werewolf isn't
that they he played a [ __ ] vampire
yeah but that's yeah no no no there were
two teams there was team vampire team
werewolf and no more pictures I never
saw the movie but apparently was a sport
movies he in shape huh is he in shape or
he's got a dancers physique I want my
Bible you know it's interesting Brian
you're talking about being in shape
you're talking about dancers physique
you got your bodies look sort of similar
in that you have you know too [ __ ]
it's a belly button working out a lot at
least but it's just still not I mean I
just need a difference it's time for a
new it's time for a new outlook on on
ourselves our physical selves and as you
know the body positivity movement is
what is hiking great gains the body posi
movement okay the body posi movement
right and so one of the things that's
happening is we're seeing it reflected
in our media whether it's the internet
whether it's the magazines that you buy
has everyone buys magazines yeah or the
movies you watch yeah you know women are
speaking a lot about you know wanting to
feel good in the skin that they're in
sure men too and this role I'm really
that I'm taking on I'm really I'm really
proud of the makers and I'm proud of the
I'm proud of actually of the history of
the part and and that it's now come full
circle not full circle but is a you're
the new Bond and the new James Bond hi
okay
now I'm the new Bond alright James hold
on no I know I know I haven't seen any
of the films but that's apparently they
say that well because I said it at the
audition they go you got the part kid
and I went I'm the new Bond and they go
yeah and I go James they said they they
are you sure they said you're the new
James Bond for the movies yes Roger
Moore and Roger Moore Sean Connery
Timothy Dalton with the new here's
Brosnan you're the new Bond uh what was
the other guy Craig Daniel Craig so
you're the new Bond yes now I'm gonna
give you a chance or Lazenby do you have
any proof of this can you bring up Will
Sasso yeah why don't you google it but
see this is what this is what's
interesting about breaking some big news
on the podcast
it's not gonna be anywhere on Google
this is a world exclusive but please
feel free well you just said it's not
gonna be anywhere on Google yeah because
I'm breaking the news here I'm actually
not supposed to talk about it when did
this come out a couple days ago so yeah
there's nothing there no there's not
there's something about American woman
on the top right because yeah there's
nothing I don't see yeah no there's
nothing yeah there's nothing about
because I'm just because I'm breaking
the news here okay and are you gonna use
an English accent huh
oh yeah no they mentioned they said
something about that look it's more
about two things it's more about that
you know bond was generally a very very
dominant shaped guy but this is what I'm
talking about yes use me wedding well
let's just go with your hands first of
all he shoots a small gun
yeah no way do your fingers fit no way
does that finger fit in the hole of a
Walther PPK sure it does it just there's
no way than a Walther PPK I don't know
what that is you're making it sound like
I got a bigger PPK like I got the kind
of fingers that look like sausages that
are busted on the barbecue when you
leave them on the inside you're like
we're good with the chicken yeah leave
the sausages on the grill and then yeah
that's a Walther PPK that's what that
yeah that's you so what's that thing
weigh about fourteen fifteen pounds
you don't know how big it is what's it
about that big no you don't know guns
that's a tiny gun what and you can you
can fit it for a silencer of you if
you've got the machinery all right but
let's see is it your finger doesn't fit
in that one of my fingers will Ryan okay
listen it's not I'm not worried about
that we'll get a bigger gun they'll make
it bigger and we'll break other
boundaries with this role of bond well
like this one you know generally bond
has been an in shape guy of one sort of
stature now it's more this now it's
gonna be a real dude
right I'm saying another thing is
traditionally eater of a man yeah sure
yes a polar bear a gentle polar bear
right man unless you get angry unless
you get angry then I'm pulling a walrus
up onto the iceberg using nothing but
the strength of my jaws and you can
google that video and and your kids
won't sleep at night okay but I'll tell
you this much another thing that we're
changing about the bond roll is
generally that's gone to a white guy so
now we're doing that a little
differently yeah with me you're a white
guy I'm a hundred percent Italian so
please don't be a real well I'm not
that's you've been being a racist piece
of [ __ ] yeah you're pretty damn white
you got blue eyes now yeah I know by now
that I'm Italian so that's Dan again
probably not probably more of a Serb
right mmm you probably know I'm from my
parents are from Napoli from nature him
over from Serbia you're a giant Serbian
giant Serbian bear you're a Serbian bear
did you say Serbian bear I said Serbia
I'm not a Serbian bear but we're
breaking new ground with bond I'm
looking really forward to playing him
and yeah yeah yeah something something
British accent I'll do my research just
like ah slaughter is with James Bond
that's right don't stir totally [ __ ] you
should have been at the audition shaken
not stirred
and mouse bomb yeah I was thinking about
coming up with some new lines for it
like like [ __ ] I'm coming in there I
doesn't sound be careful I'm coming in
there that's a really shrill voice if
this you
bring it down a little yeah you know a
friend of mine once said that oh that
you know why that guy's not a movie star
he's got a boy voice he was talking oh
he's talking about some other act he's
got a boy he's got a boy voice it's true
though isn't it
yeah guys wanna go to college but you
don't want to get student loans the
old-fashioned way and put yourself into
20 years of debt there may be a better
solution and it's called earnest it's an
app okay it's nap that helps you
navigate student loans cuz usually it's
a nightmare well guess what this is a
private student loan from a company
called earnest now a lot of times I get
a bad rap it's no wonder why for too
long they've been too confusing to
complicate it too expensive well guess
what earnest came along and said ah
there's a hole in the marketplace we can
do change this so if you still can't
afford college after scholarships grants
federal loans a new private student loan
from earnest can help you get there
earnest is designed a private student
loan for actual students in 2019 okay
meaning you can apply on your phone they
offer customizable loan terms low
interest rates and no fees they also
give you three extra months nine total
after leaving school to start paying
back your private student loan and
earnest private student loans can cover
up to one hundred percent of your school
attendance plus all you got to do
basically is fill out a two minute
eligibility check and find a cosigner if
you choose to and apply now they're
gonna do their due diligence they will
look at a lot of your financial history
because that's what a good company does
don't get annoyed by that but the school
year starting soon so if you listen to
the fighter and the kid you get $100
cash bonus when you get a private
student loan at earnest comm slash
fighter okay
that's a $100 cash bonus when you get a
private student loan at earnest comm
slash fighter and you can see terms and
conditions on that site look at them so
go to earnest comm slash fighter today
see if you can take control of your
financial future and get a real
education just don't major in something
really useless no comment
hey it's a podcast you know it's about
variety Brian you're on the cusp of
something new you know what I'm saying
are you digging what I'm so who do you
pick it up with her hanging down are you
reading my paper I sure ain't podcast as
a medium is changing and you got to
change with it so one thing we're not
gonna do on the fight or the kid is say
dumb [ __ ] like food or another thing
we're not gonna do is say you wanna talk
about sports and for [ __ ] sure what
we don't have to do anymore to say got
any burn events current events great
events they can go anywhere for current
events
they're here for you Brian they're here
for me
they're here for this hat they're here
for the truth dude you don't need to be
mushroom what's the truth yeah let's
hear it yeah you had a lung fungus it's
not curable hmm of course not
he's getting drunker and drunker I told
you many times this [ __ ] man no it's
well since that Manhattan Manhattan no
that man hat Manhattan clam chowder ah
[ __ ] New England clam chowder what woody
how many clams clams the creamy [ __ ] you
got to get that red sauce I know do but
that's a lot of clams bro
that's delicious clam will you get a lot
of zinc and clams you know you can eat
one [ __ ] clam yeah and you get all of
your nutrition yep you could be out to
sea of course I need a clam and never
worry about scurvy really Charlie yeah
good luck getting to the bottom of the
[ __ ] ocean the right and clam digger
cuz they're only found on that first
thing I said to people is when they want
to get healthy I go how many clams eat
none that's your first mistake you
[ __ ] idiot then they go on losing my
hair I go how many times you washed your
hair twice three times a week first
mistake yeah you're clogging your pores
wash your hair four times a day four
times
super dry clean that's all yeah there
get a can of that clam juice you can
find it near your pickled onions in your
groceries clam juice pickled onions my
massage that I'm in a [ __ ] scalp yep
yet to get to the beach sing some
country music and eat some clams
massaging of its lands and leeching
speaking of Italians when I was young
yeah my family and extended family we
would all go to the beach and the kids
would end the adults would dig clams and
you know pick the mussels off the rocks
up in British Columbia beautiful British
Columbia Canada and then we would just
my uncle John would throw down a like
chicken wire like it just a [ __ ] yeah
with posts it was awesome build a fire
throats but you're gonna want to just
dump all them so so I'll fish on there
I'll do you one better my mother
lemon my mother in Italy and a lot of
people would take a break take a lemon
yeah they would go and get the mussels
and the clams and eat them raw and eat
him [ __ ] raw but still does it my mom
still does that true yeah if we get
clams or mussels that moves like give me
one you know what I mean put my mom I
don't want you to I don't want you to
you know we're gonna make him moister
she'll eat the moist of course oysters
but clams and mussels with a little bit
of lemon yeah same thing yeah we're
right there and as you see oh yeah I
think she was in like Sicily or
something yeah I just don't know a stop
on the Bay of Naples and they would eat
the [ __ ] right from the sea yeah they
try to get a limited problem with that
is anti water probably ain't that clean
because everybody in Italy cuts corners
so they dumped all this [ __ ] that's true
you know I mean it's like Jerry with my
folks
yeah for foreigners you know Brian this
is the kind of refreshing conversation
that we're supposed to be happy I mean
that and a lot of your listeners have
never heard you speak like that and they
go I learned something right and now
they're gonna go to the beach in 2019
with you know lemon and they're gonna
get dysentery yeah and they're gonna
[ __ ] themselves
yeah clams just eating clams willy-nilly
at the at this Beach you happen to go to
to me not a good idea
eating mushrooms not a good idea in the
forest Louie well in the forest yeah
don't pick up watch them just eat of our
own
want to do that and if you don't know
what the berry is don't put that on your
mouth and eat the berry especially if
it's red you're if it's orange or fits
or if it's bright color or even fits
orange or you see a log don't you keep
the backup or it's red and if it's fits
blue fits black blue probably a black
probably all right probably nice long
yellow
but long if it's fits fits
away from it run away run away fits
green fits a pink get on different plans
yap yap yap yap-yap it's pink it's not a
different plan yeah now if you're in the
desert Fitz Fitz Fitz fit exist the day
you got yourself cacti with a big old
beautiful prickly pear on the end that
you can eat now don't eat it like an
apple cuz you get them you get them
little things in your tongue yeah so cut
it yeah tell you lofty coping with an
eye yeah and then you can eat it now now
well oh yes if you're if you're [ __ ]
dying of thirst in the desert you come
across a big old cacti yeah that's right
I want you to cut it in half yeah wait
take a big straw I know you have in your
backpack a big old metal straw that I
don't you bring your backpack a lot for
this purpose yeah yeah you jam it in the
middle of the cacti yeah and you suck
the water out you suck hard and true you
understand what I'm saying you know I
was in Joshua Tree National Forest a
couple years ago and there was this
cactus garden and the you know the State
Park that it is they had like little
just a little rope thing like don't go
in there
this part is the trail yeah and I was
like yeah cool but I want to take a
picture yeah so I'm gonna go into the
[ __ ] fence right you're gonna you're
going to traverse that small rope and I
and the the the you know the the cacti
were only like they were on these little
plant these little balls yeah and and
they were only knee-high and I'll tell
you it was extremely deceptive yeah
that's what it looked like and maybe
maybe I don't know it was sort of like
that but there were these little [ __ ]
balls and all of a sudden they were all
attached to my [ __ ] oh I went in
there and I and
I had to get to my my I had to get my
fly I had pliers in the truck [ __ ]
yanking like hole balls out of my lap oh
they'll get they'll get and they bore in
deep deep deep will that's why when I go
to Joshua Tree I will take secretly take
a small battery-operated chainsaw and I
cut down as many Joshua trees as i ryan
leslie will well though but they know
I've been there so III like to and then
when I go into the Sequoia National
Forest
yeah I'll vandalize some of them big old
redwoods what do you do to vandalize I
just stripped the bark all the way
around through the tree there's no
chance of living
now listen let me finish now I know
people that's controversial but yeah
those trees insult me with their height
and their ancient attitude yeah so what
I do is I you guys been here a long time
for you hello me hello me who's not easy
noggin is always one of your branches
where I can take you the [ __ ] down
romping stomping Homo sapiens dude you
know I'm saying me [ __ ] rule man
series new sheriff in town yep yep I
don't care even stand for 2,000 years
watch this yeah I'm gonna went into
three million sheets of paper there's a
there's a in the National Museum of
History I believe it is in New York City
there's a giant huge sort of long of a
tree a tree and in in the ring they have
this like it goes back to literally
Christ like some quick 2000 and then you
see in the final ring is 1976 or
something yeah and it says chopped down
by vandals and some vandals came in and
chop down a tree that was stand there
for 2,000 years is there a bigger crime
I actually think you should do the same
amount of time in jail for cutting down
a 2,000 year old tree as you do for
killing a human being I actually might
put you in jail for life you know what's
such an [ __ ] you know what you're
such an [ __ ] you know what I totally
disagree with you what would you do well
first of all people need to cut down
[ __ ] trees and when they started off
cutting down trees and they had that
technology yeah and there was nothing
but [ __ ] trees yep
he'll cut down a christ tree you need it
build a home for your family no hold on
nothing can work family think I'll get
is a better punishment yeah just being a
family if we do need to cut down a giant
Christ tree just sometimes you do
because they're sometimes they are old
they need to be chopped down there are
their reasons
yeah you take that guy you take his
family you take his extended family yes
you put them all up in that tree okay
okay yeah now they don't have anything
do with this okay no what they did had
they do have a connection a blood
connection to him a bad connection to
what to the Vandal the guy who could
chop down a family of the van take the
whole family and you take the extended
family maybe even their friends okay
they're all up in this [ __ ] tree what
are we doing what are we doing I don't
and then you chop the tree - no Brian
you really valued the Lions trees yeah
no that's not that's think it would send
a message so that people don't usually
would all I'm saying is this back in the
day before you know the Industrial
Revolution before even before that yeah
we were really logging you know with
with machines sure and figuring out how
to had a more quickly and and and more
efficiently chop down [ __ ] trees
before that yeah you just had a man and
his saw you know what that's that to me
one man and his saw a man with nothing
big acres ax saw whatever two guys with
a saw one guy with an axe yeah um that's
a good name for a podcast Brian there
you go so I would say this I would say
this that guy deserves that tree you
know nowadays 1976 yeah
no need we've got plastics we've got all
sorts of we've got metal we don't we
don't need to be chopping down trees now
but your year of the new school and you
value tree life over human life well not
have you ran the world now we'd all be
we'd all be on universal basic income
now hold on just sitting there with our
thumb or airport bought award in ER and
I know that's him that's a very unfair
characteristic of the wet bar a flaccid
dick that has never seen any Sun my dick
is not flat when I get outside this hat
and nothing else
would you say I can wear get my dick
diamond heart you can't yeah
how hard does your dick get on a scale
so so this is now this is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but this is no [ __ ] hard
bins
so my dick was my dick was super hard
and I was at my friend's house yeah and
I woke up with a piss hard-on I was
sleeping there okay I went to the
bathroom naked as I sleep naked because
you like to be naked me case I get ready
yeah so I walked I want yeah I want to
be naked if there's an intruder off yeah
I want to be going to be fighting you in
my purest that's exactly right that's
another one of the things that got me
the role of bond remind me to tell you
the story about that by the way I've got
a story about that nope nope you asked
me how hard my dick gets like I walked
and as I walked I think some bird saw my
dick and they flew away yeah and then
but my friend had a cat and the cat
there's another cat and they're about to
fight and the cats you now cats are
going and they're about to go yeah I was
like guys cut it out and I went to break
it up and they went just went and they
they converged yeah my [ __ ] got in the
middle of that blasted hold on like I'm
being honest I'm not trying to be a dick
Bryan so far this podcast has been about
on is hold on if I say Weyland jail can
about tell you how my dick is hard
enough and how hard it is and as they
fought they got my dick in the middle
and they blunted their claws on my Brian
well they do that is truly their Lord
they both died between them going No yep
and my dick didn't have a scratch on it
now that's that's I know and that's a
[ __ ] well that's what's crazy about
how hard my dick gets now now now it is
what it is now can I tell you a story
about not lying I can show you right now
I could show you right now on my phone
but all right because I have it on video
but now listen don't sneeze okay now I
got a story about to sneeze I got a
story about fighting naked okay Jimmy
Burke who you know I know Jimmy Burke I
love Jimmy Jimmy Burke's I think it's
his well his okay his his cousin no his
his nephew he's a police officer
Staten Island they got a call when they
get there an intruder had come in and he
was he was well
let me go they the woman answers and
she's in a robe and she's half-naked and
he goes what's going on sis there's an
intruder in our house and my husband is
fighting him okay so they come running
in and they find the guy who's a big
athletic guy he's naked as the day is
long and he's got the guy in a [ __ ]
guillotine choke only who had broken in
yeah and they go let go and he goes I'm
not [ __ ] letting go not letting go
this guy cuz the guy had come in yeah
with a weapon apparently yeah and Adam
for yeah well so but he had him there
and he said let him go we got him and
they cuff him yeah and they and he's
holding on him and when they when he let
him go
the guy was blue and dead was he had so
what that happened was they were [ __ ]
on the couch this guy who was a rough
can't wait and what's with Jimmy's
connection so his his his I believe his
nephew I'll check with him I think it's
his nephew through them through a
marriage his his nephew was one of the
cops on this case okay they come in so
they were [ __ ] on the couch a dude
breaks thinking they're not in the house
breaks the [ __ ] window and jumps into
the living room
Jesus the guy's mid mid mid stroke yeah
pulls out obviously with a hard-on you
may as well you may as well get the jump
on a [ __ ] Doberman Pinscher who's
having said correct idiot correct
because if you're a real man like me
yeah and and diamond dick over here yeah
diamond dick that's your new nickname
thanks brother dick is a good day you
don't [ __ ] wear it let me tell you
something yeah go ahead
you don't wear a cowboy hat the whole
[ __ ] podcast and not acknowledge your
friend has a diamond hard day thanks for
hey thanks brother
got it you're in my corner you always
have been I appreciate that hey you know
I got a piss hole too you know why I got
a diamond shaped piss hole diamond shape
oh yeah I got a rata diamond hard dick
time to DDP diamond shape diamond shaped
pistol yep and it's and it's not small
either you can you can pie stick that
index finger right right right I could
take a [ __ ]
Sharpie yep with the lid on and now for
an organic carrot yeah one of those
organic carrots not too big but
definitely not small ah it sting get it
right in my deck or this [ __ ] or this
[ __ ] Johnsonville bratwurst of a
thumb that I have that Italian found
that Serbian Italian that Serbian
Italian thought I if I grow my nail a
little long it's not Serbian I hope I
could shuck an oyster with that thumb
and I got a stick I got a piece of
leather in my help you let us come here
Brian and he'll [ __ ] shoot right down
rather even though join up yeah we're
both heterosexual dudes
sure we are that's well you're like more
you're like you're the two nose my
standard white male that's right Italian
I want to apologize to my sister and her
white male Ness yeah and and and my
supremacy and he'll go any way he cha he
comes out the guy naked yeah we got we
went off on a finger tangent you know
you're all top five of my [ __ ]
favorite movie stars best buddy you know
I'm saying pound it out thanks buddy so
diamond dick came at the guy and the guy
grabbed his legs and he put him in the
old guillotine no [ __ ] and [ __ ]
killed him naked and hard-on while his
girl watched him and then just was like
get him honey yeah then he slew a man
that's pretty romantic it is he stole a
man in his house and I want my question
is I wonder if they finished up after
that I was that stressed you gotta let
your stress go his cortisol levels are
sky-high yeah he just killed a man
he said he goes am I gonna be in trouble
yeah cop said what are you talking about
you're a hero got broken wheelhouse yeah
oh that's great it's just an island well
yeah yeah that's true the cops are like
we'll handle it yeah normally in most
situations there's gonna be some
paperwork
yeah well now in this case I want to say
this if you are having sex with your
girl yeah and a guy broke in yeah I
think all due respect yeah I love you
think I believe I love you to that
because you're a sensitive guy yeah you
would piss and [ __ ] okay to fall to the
ground and scream maybe it's not true or
now that is absolute you fall on your
back and piss straight up in the air no
and douse yourself with a bunch of pee
and then loose control your bowels [ __ ]
the floor yeah and then scream mommy at
the top of your lungs is that
would happen in a manner of speaking
Brian that is what would happen and I'll
tell you why no shame in that does the
number one as soon as I hear that as
soon as I hear someone fumbling with my
door my gal who would be on top of me at
this place on top of you she'd be on top
of me because I'd be asleep and with a
rock hard day he says yeah and then
she'd just get him and then I'd say I'd
say maybe I got to handle some business
and then she'd roll off by the way my
girl's little dog sleeps under the bed
look out when they're over and and she's
a cute little first mistake we're having
a little dog get a bigger dog yet but
I'm saying you know I got to protect
them both all right
adorable little dog yeah so I would go
babe I got some I got some business to
handle yeah the little the pooch oh yeah
I go
stay back Ronnie yep and then I then I
would 100% piss up in a fountain while
the guys still trying to get the door
with me into my own nook the reason for
this don't worry about it man my urine
contains so much testosterone but it's
gonna get me [ __ ] full snortin mad so
you soon as I can
drink your own urine yes and a lot of it
would go up my nose now you know your
test is [ __ ] Jack my test is Jack yes
next thing you said wasn't gonna [ __ ]
myself yeah well if I have time to get
over to the toilet I will if not you
know I probably just maybe grab the
closest pair of jeans or and would you
sit in your hand cowboy hats that I have
if I had to I and would you throw it in
would you would you have two handfuls to
fiddle handfuls of sass oh [ __ ] no and
then when the guy comes in would you box
his ears with it that's not the regime
that dies
the reason that I'm [ __ ] is to it's
like when a boxer a fighter makes weight
my [ __ ] as you know because you're a
good friend of mine weighs anywhere from
20 to 35 pounds that's one of my shits
so and I like to eat late at night yeah
when I eat late at night I eat a lot
okay so I'll take one of those massive
dumps yep
25 pounds [ __ ] yeah now AM aerodynamic
yeah it's time to work out you wouldn't
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] like right in front of
the door so when the guy walks and he
goes goddamn I got jet net boom you
[ __ ] right
those are parlor tricks I want to [ __ ]
mom I want to [ __ ] honest one-on-one
with this man okay the last thing you
said was what ice cream mommy yes I
would I'd say this is for my mother
which is what I say before I kill every
man though and that number is in the
dozens so a lot of men with your hands
are with with that's two piles of [ __ ]
here again I have had some dirty Dookie
on my digits when it's time to [ __ ]
battle down with the dude I gotta reach
up into my hole to get some out if I'm
eating a lot of meat okay so your reason
again that I lose wet it lose the weight
when I [ __ ] is to make weight for a fair
fight
okay I'll get down for MU I don't know
about right now how much would you say
that I win be honest and be honest and
don't be insulting how much do I'm not
gonna be insulting all right
I mean if I have lost some weight with
your clothes on huh with your clothes on
no make it a [ __ ] and I will gear down
right here with my bird hanging out for
it I don't know I'm guessing weight dude
I'm six foot three all right so then so
five No are you serious no you look
you're actually you're look all right
you're looking at you're looking at 300
I'm gonna give you 300
that's that would have been fair in the
past I've been working out a lot with
our boy Nick yep Brian right my boy the
trainer to me Nick flour
yeah Nick flour he's the [ __ ] but no
more class he is Ryan and I don't like
to you know choose our times when we
work that's true he's overdosed gym yeah
he's a [ __ ] frenzy right [ __ ] I
said there's a lot of gyms on the street
he goes he goes yeah and you can step
into any number of him if you want to
learn nothing he's the best Nick is the
best he's the best trainer I've ever had
really far always [ __ ] phenomenal
because he knows movement so well yeah
and I'll do something he goes Wow okay
very mediocre you wanted you want to do
it right or you got this though you
would you got this I'll start doing my
own thing because all you got this it's
okay my feet me up yesterday I'm sore as
[ __ ] right now
really we went deadlift and bench oh wow
yeah he I had my shoulders all [ __ ] up
and I thought it was
tendinitis he said you move very well he
said I moved I said you move very well
your movement isn't great he said how
about that well I'm an athlete Brian and
then he had me rolling on a [ __ ] one
of those little rollers on my lap and my
shoulder with it was amazing
he understands the the thing at the same
thing to me yes sir I had to lose some
weight for a show and they said we want
you to loot the answer the question by
the way before I kill anybody and when I
make weight is a lean 205 pounds so
anyway um but 200 to move on from there
huh 205 I'm around to I I go anywhere
from 190 to - oh that's so anyway um so
anyway so anyway moving heavier this so
anyway that make you like only thirty
pounds so anyway okay so um anyway they
wanted me to lose some weight for a show
and I told you this I'm like I got to
get a trainer that you know the [ __ ]
networks gonna pay for it whatever and
they wanted me to lose some weight and
and I was like I said it my manager I
said how much they go whatever you can
get and I go I'm thinking in the time
I'm like maybe I could look maybe I
could lose 15 pounds the problem with
that is you're not gonna see it yeah I'm
I'm yeah so Danielle my manager of 23
plus years at this point she's
incredible she's like well they just
want you to be healthy [ __ ] don't
give a [ __ ] if I die tomorrow they want
me to lose [ __ ] weight yeah and I'll
do my best but I'm telling you I could
show up if you've lost how much lying
around I think I've lost around 25
pounds well it's kind of a it's kind of
a hack dude first I'm still working out
with Nick even after we shot the show I
dropped I think I dropped about 10
pounds before we shot that show and you
can't find but my girl is a trainer and
the nutritionist and a private chef and
a dish and so she it's like I don't eat
anything anymore yeah there's that yeah
I just eat a lot of curse if first
vegetables I'm not even eating fruit
right why don't you just eat like a
[ __ ] Inuit and get yourself a big bag
of semi-frozen reindeer when I was up on
that you know when I was up in the
Arctic shooting
film the Grizzlies there's this one
[ __ ] country store that I like to go
by because they had arctic char smoked
arctic I like I like smoked oh [ __ ] this
is the most purest fish it's in a lake
that's pristine never been touched yeah
beautiful and Nathaniel and Mandy would
go up there and they would go fish it
this guy Mindy from Mac Quebec and then
nate from from Kamloops BC right and
they'd go up there and fish so anyway I
go into this country store and you open
up the freezer and you'll see some
arctic char you'll also see a [ __ ]
seals head also said you'll see oh yeah
oh how about some [ __ ] hooks
how about some reindeer hooves you can
eat reindeer oh do they make a stupid
they eat every family there as a matter
of fact when we were making that film
and honestly it's not out in America yet
but if you're in Canada and you haven't
seen the Grizzlies which is the number
one I'm not even gonna talk about the
movie it isn't something that I think
Indiana Dayani I think every Canadian
should see this film it's a very
important movie for a lot of reasons and
holy crap these kids forget it Miranda
depen CA the director went down there
early of course she shot up short five
years previous just to you know get up
there and get into it and get and learn
about this movie that she was originally
producing on there's my it's about the
First Nation people right yeah it's
about it's about the Inuit kids it's
more specifically about this fella named
Russ Shepard is a real dude from
Saskatchewan sketchy yeah did you say
Saskatchewan did you try to correct my
enunciation of a Canadian yeah it's a
sketch one a province or city it's a
province you [ __ ] just escaped death
right there okay there's a picture of
rust there's there's Russ with Miranda
Wally Beckett who's the writer yeah who
wrote on Breaking Bad and justified
Jesus and there's Miranda depen ceated
the director and there's Russ Shepard
this dude got out of college and shows
up in code look took Nunavut population
1,000 and he was a teacher there you
know he was just out of college and he
got placed there and the kids on and and
there are big people than you and yes or
no huh short short people there
they're people of all different sizes
and shape and that's been schnitzer who
plays Russ in the film yeah and then I
play the other white guy in the movie
yeah who also works at the school yeah
Mike so anyway so anyway Russ he shows
up there and these kids you know they
got there's some social problems in and
it had the highest suicide rate
yeah of anywhere in North America well
because it stays correct never wrong
dark 24/7 and well for first you know
during the winter months yeah yeah why
it stays bright that Dan said which is
why in the winter months they have a lot
of vampire slangs to those vampires like
the dark and they can roam around all
day and night yes it never is day there
yeah that's right say there's a lot of
vampires you have to sleep with a smile
collar but yeah but I can you can also
see vampires in that freezer at the
Country Store it's great oh yeah yeah
okay but when they turn into a bat
gotcha they make those make great soup
instead yeah I love so soon yeah I love
bats too have you read Brian's
children's book bats too so anyway Russ
shows up there and you know the problems
that are I'm not gonna sit here and tell
you about just go see the movie there
are there are there are you know
residential schools and things that have
altered the Inuit way of life from the
from the perspective of you know it
becoming Canada underneath their feet
right right so there's a lot of issues
going on in this film and it's really
[ __ ] something Russ Shepard was up
there introduce the kids to lacrosse
because he played lacrosse in college
he's in the cross guy and it's the story
of that and these [ __ ] kids most of
them had almost all of them that are
play the young kids in this movie that
go to the high school had never acted
before Miranda workshopped all these
kids and everyone was making their own
plays and videos and this and that the
kids that didn't make you know the parts
or whatever half we're all so background
in the movie it was [ __ ] incredible
the entire Nunavut is the is the is the
you know First Nations Inuit Territory
and it was a cold
were shooting them winter no in the
spring yes and what were some days where
it was really [ __ ] hot you'd be on
the ocean and the whole crew would be
down to t-shirts Wow
the Sun is is its reflect reflecting off
of the ice off the oh but nighttime it
gets cold again pull - it and assuring
the day there were also some day I the
coldest day I'd ever experienced was was
while we're shooting the film anyway
these [ __ ] kids they [ __ ] tear me
apart and and I love them they're
incredible you'll see the [ __ ] movie
if you're in Canada Grizzlies
can't see it here in the United States
no you can't see that here yet no and
you can't see American woman in Canada
so I got about it I got in both cover
I'm gonna watch these two movies hey
watch these two movies an American woman
I can see in theaters in select theaters
you can see in Los Angeles right now all
right hey man you want to go have like
three or four bottles of wine and go to
American woman sure I do and let my
hands roam what you wear shorts and I'm
gonna tug your [ __ ] putt we'll do that
come on
it's a pun I tell you what I think you
got a [ __ ] putt I got a [ __ ] the
this thumb right here when your name
when you look like the letter Q that's
what I said out loud so we look like IQ
together cuz you're a [ __ ] nail thin
no dude we look like lq i got a dick on
me so I don't eat anything anymore
I got I look like a letter L with legs I
look like I look like a Q that's
constantly just like this with that with
the the [ __ ] hog part up in the air
like that just wouldn't mean a hog part
the [ __ ] keep this thing well on me
it's a hog because I got to piss holes
and my dick is bright paint it I have no
say disgusting it's just it's like a tin
of Morton's salt and it just stops why
don't you have a head dude was in an
accident yeah what kind of accident it
was a piercing ender trap bear trap yeah
I was true I was trying to stick my dick
in a law to snapping turtles were about
to fight yeah that's right I was at my
friend's house and I had to piss and I
won't be able to piss hard on yeah and
then I got between them
it's amazing that at 52 I still haven't
lost our goddamn step I'll tell you that
much yeah man it right is something
that's something compliment me on my
[ __ ] hat say something nice about my
hat well yep
I'm not gonna do it so anyway um yeah my
girl has me nothing nothing
so I like your girl and I like what
she's doing for you she's wonderful
it is hard to say you know because she's
like the [ __ ] at what she does and then
I had to lose weight for this thing and
she's like do you want me to help ya cuz
we had just started dating she knows her
[ __ ] for that she knows her [ __ ] but it
means that I have to respect what the
[ __ ] she's saying about the [ __ ] that
she's goin well something else because I
can't be like come on I'm gonna eat this
she'll be like okay fine go ahead but
I'm not gonna help well the promises of
a troll doesn't really work you got to
do something else when it comes to
anything 80 in life you have a
compulsion for which we all have I think
all of us if you don't have some kind of
addiction of some kind you probably a
bore yeah he does create him cats cats
cat loves huge very muscular black guys
and you like food now hey I got nothing
look kidding dis my own shirt what's
your addiction do you have a thing mmm
probably eating I eat like an [ __ ]
oh you do okay so a lot of best right
Heating has a lot of yeah I know you go
through that sometimes it's just if you
eat yourself to death at night it's not
unlike being [ __ ] drunk yes you're
releasing all those endorphins for me
you know look let's not get into it uh
sure clinical depression can lead to
some bad choices when you're eating late
at night sure yeah what is your go-to
food when you're binging if I'm eat now
I don't do this anymore yeah and if you
within the sound of my voice maybe you
are doing this maybe this is something
you're doing really helped in this
podcast now oh sure it's oh it's a
problem when it's late at night and
let's say again I'm not doing this
anymore also because I I'm trying to
lose weight for another thing and I'm
kind of on lockdown remember when we
were on the 10-minute podcast and I east
when we were on remember when we did the
ten minute remember when we were yeah
remember we did the time in the podcast
I used to invite people that in public
to just come up and
thumb my calves yes and just get into
him need them like dough yeah I make a
new challenge if you see me eating a
cheeseburger yeah check it out of my
[ __ ] hand Jesus Christ I don't give a
[ __ ] now care if you wanna know why I'm
saying that why
oh that ol actually only goes for the
year 2019 ya don't fits after that if
it's and you're having to listen to this
podcast in 2031 yeah
please don't kick me while I'm sitting
there probably with me cuz we'll might
kill you might scalp here he'll pull you
he's been known to grab a man's hair and
pull it right off his head I'll turn you
into a [ __ ] burger and by then it'll
be Trump's martial law and you know
that's right they'll be MIT there won't
be many ways to punish a white guy for
turning anyone into a [ __ ] hamburger
right you wanna think you think we were
[ __ ] to trees wait until 2031 I'm
writing a book about it oh man so so
anyway she's got me on lockdown so I
don't [ __ ] eat anything but before
that one thing I would do it would be
late at night you know it's [ __ ]
Saturday you know and maybe maybe I'm
just gonna chill out
maybe I'm just gonna stay at home sure
maybe watch a movie shoot maybe I'd have
a hoot or two of marijuana yeah I don't
normally talk about that sort of thing
that's okay we're being very honest yeah
I don't drink alcohol right and I a
little weed goes a long way a little
just a little bit nothing like that and
I and I'm from British Columbia where
there's weed aplenty and couldn't wait
very good weed and I didn't even really
touch the [ __ ] until I was almost 40 so
kids don't smoke weed but uh oh the
[ __ ] the the the emotional eatin
polar bear just had a little bit of
wheat
oh [ __ ] and it's late at night and we're
watching wrestling yeah that now seemed
about to get so now you're watching
wrestling late at night yep and you got
now is weed does we accentuate your
depression no or doesn't but it just
does mosey almost hungry well yeah
perhaps if I smoke a bunch of weed then
maybe the weed makes you feel I'm
feeling great and and by the way when
you're feeling great you're relaxed why
not treat yourself
treat yourself oh that's all you know
what we're trying to do good things so
we're gonna eat healthy foods yeah we're
gonna order we're not gonna order a
pizza how we're gonna fool ourselves in
order
hi food because what you could do when
you order from a Thai food restaurant is
order healthy things yeah you know you
could get some oh one of the things I
like to get from Thai restaurants is
Morning Glory
it's just sauteed watercress with garlic
no big deal
what if you just got that and some brown
rice right yeah let me take that big 15
pound [ __ ] in the night be ready for
that intruder
yeah but not will sasso no sure he gets
the Morning Glory sure he gets the brown
rice
I've diet coke with that I boiled Edna
so we got a gateway we got a gateway
yeah now you're gonna stop there oh
sorry is there anything else you'd like
the order how about some don't accent
yeah that's a good accent yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay uh my only friends who do type
my only white friends who do Thai
accents are my friends Johan and Cyrus
the Sheila Jeff Brothers the Walter
White and Jesse Pinkman is she legit
because they were there for they both
have Asian wives but they were there for
living there for like over ten years I
need I think speak fluent I does that
allow it train more time to ask no Asian
I can say I trained more time so I can
tell us a lot
I trained Muay Thai for years because
some guys some guys in the US see when
they roundhouse when they'll kick like
legs okay that their their corner will
go by and why it may have Miller
somebody's guy was there it said the
mayhem Miller got in a fight with like
literally ten dudes in some in Florida
Miami and they were all like these giant
roid heads and they didn't know who they
were [ __ ] with and mayhem was dancing
with a girl woman and the guy goes hey
bro get the [ __ ] out of here
he goes to try to punch mayhem a hell
knows he steps out just cuz I ain't
getting [ __ ] crazy guys face down on
this knee
and his friend said that mayhem was out
in the street and he was just quiet oh I
just throw elbows those guys are coming
and hit him and smiling alright and
there was a bodies there was like a
mountain of bodies all around him he was
just literally out of a movie like you
[ __ ] with mayhem Miller you [ __ ]
big muscular roid head Speer had no idea
and they beat up like literally a gang
of dudes like a gang of guys just that
kept coming he's just been going alright
mayhem Miller smiles when he fights oh
he's the best yeah I miss that it's us
again I dude where's Ethan I don't know
I think yeah probably a few blocks from
here
so we get some Thai food there's mayhem
[ __ ] love it we get some Thai food
right we meaning me and how about some
pad wound sent right oh it's just rice
it's just rice noodles with some egg
some chicken well that rice noodle is
[ __ ] just straight rights gluten you
think oh it's good for you because it's
rice and then you know let's try the
fish balls and maybe some chicken larb
[ __ ] make it pork larb and let me get
the chicken wings and that's it so we
got about 8,000 calories okay so that's
that's gonna be good for an 11:00 p.m.
meal what my finish you're gonna finish
all of all of it okay I'm getting even
the little parts of noodles that are
broken off and her in the [ __ ] yeah
the tin I saw you eat 24 chicken wings
did you bones and all because you were
talking and you you were you were you
were gonna come home hungry I was like
he's he's crunching just the wing part
if it's good bride right you ate all of
it you're bones left you can't eat the
flat you can't eat the two little bones
now the tibia and the fibula bring up
bring up when those hyenas or that end
those animals
drag the antelope into the into that
African Hotel in the lobby take a look
at this these these these these hyenas
chase down a kudu or something in a
hotel that's in Africa and
they had at it in the lobby of this
5-star resort and you might want to see
might want a [ __ ] mess is it the one
that Bo I don't know is that the one
that says bloody mess now normally I'd
[ __ ] on Brian for interrupting my story
with that story about wild animals while
I'm trying to talk about being a fat guy
ordering food and I want to get back
this is really interesting yeah so this
is this is what you're what you have
following view shows me upsets the this
is good
oh here they are because there was a big
commotion there's a rhino [ __ ]
yeah around barefoot there's [ __ ]
rhinos [ __ ] don't worry about it all
right now everybody's got guns and there
you go well here's the here's the Lariat
go oh that's what happens when hyenas ah
no I mean oh they ate the face off the
[ __ ] oh yeah they didn't get a chance
to really get enough of it but yeah
[ __ ] why'd they go they went to its
organs yeah that's where the only
difference in that video is if you had
had that could who there would be
nothing left if the GU that would
probably be nothing left or would be let
clean a blood and you know what I'll
tell you this much we're shooting the
Grizzlies up in the Arctic you'd be
having stew on set you know late second
meal and you'd go around towards the
bottom of the [ __ ] caribou stew yeah
with the ladle and you'd pull up no [ __ ]
[ __ ] antler I'd be like why the [ __ ]
not there's marrow in there so
absolutely I'll fry those I'll fry those
antlers down
yep Thai chicken wing style yep and I'll
eat them so that's fine right that's
that that's what we've that's what we've
done well a little bit later they really
did [ __ ] up that that poor nothing's
dead a little bit later maybe you want
something sweet well where I live in Los
Feliz there's all sorts of like [ __ ]
you know creameries open late at night
oh no so you've got 8,000 calories now
now we got to get some dessert and maybe
get some maybe get some dessert
yeah or [ __ ] it let's just let's just
postmates 7-eleven that way we'll get
just it we'll get some [ __ ] talking
about
haagen-dazs ice cream that's right now
you gotta hit the little cups yeah yeah
but they only cut what little cup so
it's too hard to order get the [ __ ]
thing
I won't eat at all
and then maybe just you know [ __ ] it
maybe do a Twix no KitKat I'll get both
no no just the KitKat and the Snickers
no twigs and the clicks and then and
maybe but I want something salty with
that so maybe some potato chips that's a
lot also like those Fritos chips those
chili and cheese Fritos chili cheese
those are really good so let's get both
of those those and I think that's it
gummy bears and then so we'll get that
and then now we're really [ __ ] now
we're laying on the couch and we're
watching you know we're watching NXT you
know shout out to Kyle O'Reilly and the
undisputed era and you know we're and
then we're good right yeah we're good
we're good but now we're [ __ ] we've
had a little bit of marijuana we ate
some Thai food we had a little more
marijuana yeah we had some sweets
yeah so now we got a bed right it's 4:00
in the morning
yeah so we gotta get to bed now you're
texting Saturday night yeah we have a
thing me Will Sasso Marshall Cooke and
Chris D'Elia have a text thread that's
been going from your eyes and and we
it's called guy said gee I think right
now it's just called [ __ ]
yeah it's called [ __ ] and we it's
usually called guys and we and basically
we'll we have this thing where we'll
never sleeps
well it's awake Chris whatever text cuz
Chris could be really early going you
know coming back on a flight from
somewhere he could be up really late cuz
he likes to stay up late but usually
only till around - yeah or something
like that
but it doesn't matter when he texts I
text back and Chris says hey will
it detects that hey will why are you
simply always awake yeah that's right
11:30 a.m. this Y are you awake cuz York
because 4 a.m. your waist 8 p.m. you
wake 6:30 a.m. you wish marijuana food
yeah cuz marijuana well I just never do
I keep odd hours but back a little while
ago it could have been that yeah it
would have been that his marijuana slash
food and and and depression now now it's
now you've had your sweets and had a
little more marijuana that's a lot of
food with yet gummy bears we got we got
potato chips we got that tub of
haagen-dazs we got Twizzlers these small
twigs yeah okay Twix we got a kick
yeah we send out wheels so now we're now
we're good
yeah only we're not because maybe we had
a little bit more weed and we're
watching some really interesting reps
but surely you're watching takeover
Brooklyn and we're like but surely your
sofa what have they done with osku since
she left NXT nothing they should have
kept that [ __ ] winning streak going
yeah and you know we're just what we're
watching a Velveteen dream the dude is
so [ __ ] over
yeah right melt Velveteen dream versus
Matt riddle you saw that sure did I mean
[ __ ] riddle pulled it beat the [ __ ]
out of them for a half hour and [ __ ]
velvetine still pulls it out on believe
that's a character he simply the [ __ ]
yeah you know that they simply this year
he's the [ __ ] so then then it's like
okay well now it's getting early yeah so
maybe I'll just stay up a little bit
let's get some breakfast but hold on
yeah but let's get some breakfast I know
but you just had so much Oh what's the
only thing that's open for breakfast
McDonald's oh good call but there's also
Denny's which is more healthy than
McDonald's because you can sit down in
it oh you can also sit down at
McDonald's mm-hmm toss it up let's do
Denny's today it's never been more than
three I'd like to embellish in the story
and say that I had also ordered
McDonald's now but I have ordered from
three different things in one evening so
crap yeah that's really bad that's
that's a real food addiction yeah that
well a binge yeah that's a binge now
food addiction you have a way cuz I'm
going through therapy yeah and I find it
me too gotta stay in it you gotta stand
it because my therapist speaking of any
kind of compulsion or when you want to
do something that you're not supposed to
do whatever it might be
there will be this idea of having a
relationship with your shadow side with
the side of yourself not even trying to
fix it but just just have a relationship
with that guy who maybe isn't who you
should be all the time you understand I
think all of us have I think all of us
are who we were
who we are who we could be and we also
have in my opinion two [ __ ] lies to
our personality we got the light and we
got the dark we got the we got good old
Bry and then we got shadow Bryan yeah
guys will there's and I think all of us
have that don't we
no Bryan parts of our personality sure
most of the time yeah friendly polar
bear yep but then occasionally I'm that
brown black colossal grizzly yeah who
eats humans I'll eat the Thai restaurant
you'll eat legs first too
yeah okay so do you have a way of
[ __ ] eat your antlers do you have a
way of helping other people have this
food yeah tomorrow's a new day you know
uh
get up don't hate yourself it's the
hardest thing in the world to love
yourself right yeah well it's not the
heart is yeah no I don't think the human
beings are programmed to love themselves
all the time when they do that's called
Scioscia maybe maybe yeah I mean by the
way maybe loving yourself isn't so good
for you because what drives you a lot of
times is the need to compensate for a
shortcoming in my opinion there's a
explain what well if you love yourself a
lot you'd be a smiling puppy yeah you'd
be [ __ ] up and you're gonna be there's
gonna be bad days and you're not gonna
be able to explain them and I don't
think our puny human minds can't so just
a [ __ ] go I'm having a bad day
did you order some Thai food you [ __ ]
up enjoy the [ __ ] out of it enjoy every
[ __ ] bite right and then tomorrow
wake up and you know maybe write
something down see what it is you want
to do for the week yeah maybe for the
month because I'll forget I'll go oh I'm
eating right I'm doing and doing it good
and then a few days ago bagel what
happened to that thing I was doing
anyway died food McDonald's but let me
let me piggyback on that because the
other thing I think is people always try
to look to when they set goals and they
look at the top of the mountain I gotta
lose all its weight or I gotta I gotta
get busy and I gotta get my real estate
license I know hold on hold on just try
doing one tiny thing every day like I
actually believe in in consistency and
I'm talking about read one page people
say you wanna get into real estate read
one page of a book that's it why
five minutes of sub of a guy who talking
about real estate on YouTube I mean one
tiny little thing every day
tiny five minutes eat one less chicken
wing one less chicken just one less
chicken wing you could order more just
to eat one less sure you're up a net
more yeah
let's say you ordered 10 yeah but you
ate them all the next time order 20 and
eat 19 I'm joking of course
all I'm yeah that doesn't really work no
I would say wake up and [ __ ] try to
go for a goddamn walk do one go do some
movement one [ __ ] I don't have your
[ __ ] answers all I know is that
everybody [ __ ] deals with [ __ ]
you might be looking at me and going hey
Will Sasso I enjoyed you in the
Grizzlies and I can't wait to drive to
the United States to watch American
movie maybe you're on the floor woman
yeah not American we've gotta say it
right yeah I know yeah I got that movie
with that [ __ ] long-haired Christina
and I should have been starring Bryan
Callen yeah but he was busy yeah I don't
know that you guys would have pulled off
I can do anything I don't know if I
could yeah but I don't know anything
that was necessary of the I'm as good an
actor as anybody's ever left keep calm
okay
and you're saying hey I'm gonna soldier
in south to watch American woman and I
think you're great well I like your hat
and your stories and your cover of
Luckenbach Texas by Waylon Jennings and
I'm over here going oh I'm a fat sack of
[ __ ] because I just ate fish balls
fried fish balls from the Thai place and
I'll chase it with some [ __ ] more a
steel head or a steel head and innovate
in none of it they eat that steel head
raw oh yeah you wouldn't find actually I
don't think you don't have a Sheila head
no you wouldn't find a steel head I
don't think you I did see some other
heads here a liar no no I saw a walrus
skin yeah you'd get it yeah yeah they I
forget what it's called walrus skin anew
so one of the kids in the movie he would
eat he loved walrus skin he would eat
walrus where he lived his town was even
smaller and cooked look at that a lot of
fish there we go seal seal yeah yep damn
yeah they eat that seal right there yeah
seal I didn't eat any see
that looks like blop you know that
blubber yeah yeah that's the fat in the
skin uh I don't know if there's some
flesh oh it's all blubber hi could
there's a frozen one there you go
yeah I don't know that you'd eat because
you eat it raw
you eat the seal raw huh it's gonna be
very fishy booboo Stewart one of the
actors in the movie he plays he's the
only one who plays an Inuit kid who's
actually not First Nations Boo Boo's
actually from here and so him myself and
bench netzer were the only ones from out
of town and tan to pardon all I don't
know where tend to live but I believe
she lives in Kent asked on to but I and
but Boo Boo and Ben 8/8 Narwhal and they
said it was a feeling that made them it
made it tasted bad and it made them feel
bad really probably a lot of like I
don't know they had like a bite annoyed
I mean D or something missed it you know
you can heat that [ __ ] like if you eat
some polar bear liver you'll die of some
kind of overload of I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is but you can't eat you
can't eat polar bear liver but it will
leave polar bear oh yeah my friend
Jordan who spent time with the Inuit
said they basically they it's the
hunting is just the way of life yeah
that's how yes sir it's a hunting yeah
well by the way the food that's up there
if you want to buy western food as they
call it it's very expensive
yeah funniest thing I saw was there's
this one food co-op place and there was
a bucket of chicken nuggets like frozen
chicken nuggets the way you'd find
anywhere $61 Wow yeah because it's got I
mean it's got to travel and there's also
some some other you know dealio with the
food and why it's expensive and it's
kind of a [ __ ] ripoff and so there's
[ __ ] over there you see so let's live
off the land up there yeah
not me so much but fish reindeer wall
fish Narwhal though is dude let me tell
you this a lot of let in that is mercury
yeah sure in the big old and that you
get way up north and Baffin you know the
North Pole yeah it's all pure there's no
way we should [ __ ] up the planet all the
way to the North Pole Brian stop
listening to stop watching CNN
okay we're fine we're gonna be fine
those water levels aren't rising all
right you know yeah being up there was a
was a hell of a [ __ ] trip Bannack
banika oh well that is so good the well
flash and then dried Kanak is good
though Bannack is really good bannocks
just fried bread so I was getting
recipes from the locals you like
yourself some but you can't really go on
a narwhal slash caribou slash arctic
char slash beluga whale binge I'm sure I
could do and you I'll find a way to cook
[ __ ] polar bear liver with onions
well what did you do when you had that
food compulsion in Europe shooting the
Grizzlies there was one place of it
there was big racks BBQ and this guy
Mike up their own big racks BBQ and he
actually I owe him an email he's he let
me borrow his van he had five delivery
vans and he was like you want a van yeah
like sure he goes yeah usually three of
them are in the shop but I got all five
right now this is a Quebec guy that you
are dr. Farr though you don't break down
you can't drive too far in the Arctic
Brian the roads don't go anywhere they
have um this is gonna be a stupid
question and it might be a very ignorant
one there are polar bear out there yeah
they're polar bear yeah so how far out
of the town are polar bear cuz though
out far they don't want to be around
humans they don't cuz they get shot I
don't know why exactly but they'll eat
the [ __ ] out of you that walking in in
the Canadian government and I don't know
what the with the Inuit and elders what
their what their you know what their
influence on this is but the deal is no
more than 20 in Nunavut per season can
go can die so you can hunt polar bear
but it's can only you there's only 20 no
no not per person I'm talking total the
entire time
only 20 different yeah it's very
difficult to win that lottery why would
anybody want to kill a beautiful polar
bear in addition to eat it only to eat
it and keep that [ __ ] that beautiful
skin is seller or where it land if you
want if you want to wear it people make
a lot of their own a lot of their own
clothing yes yeah so yeah no it's purely
to eat it this it's like a windfall when
someone in the village it's like they
get that lottery ticket you know they
get to hunt a bear all of their friends
are going with them and that it's meat
for whoever they know and they send I
guess it's good from what I understand
that's how it works yeah I did not try
any pair me I didn't try any bear that
would be cannibalism for me because you
know I'm a bear okay I'm a big huge I'm
a big happy polar yeah all the time but
you know what's interesting is this guy
Nate who's a very interesting dude is
like an expat from from British Columbia
he was up there and you know there's a
bunch of people that are like white
people that are like just like I live up
here and this other guy Mende who I said
this Quebec guy but Nate was like
explained to me the the trading like the
what the hierarchy is and it's not money
money is not at the top it was like I
think it was like meat and fish and then
booze and then like weed and then then
money and then [ __ ] like plane tickets
and stuff because ah yeah I was really
makes sense you can actually use yeah
yeah because he was telling me he was
like he was like he said uh yeah I'm
gonna probably go down and visit la had
never been right and he was like telling
me how he oh he goes because I fly
everywhere in Canada for like nothing
hey I could fly down to I go why so if
you're in you it and you work for the
Inuit airline you get these vouchers
that you can fly anywhere in the in
Nunavut or the territories to I believe
in northern Canada for free and then you
get one buddy pass and so you you you
you you're you work for the for the
airline and your your your your whatever
your husband your wife your cohort can
take the other it can take the other
pass well Nate had a pass I go well
how'd you get this he goes I know a gal
who works for the airlines and there
her husband doesn't like to fly won't
fly so I get that airline pass and I use
it all over Canada I go visit my
grandkids and round round I go what do
you give her he goes I give her an
amount of goods that equal around say to
300 bucks a month you know and I go
what's that he goes I don't you worry
about that but it's like arctic char
yeah pot yeah like yeah they're trading
of the bullets it's awesome it's it's
it's a very let's put it this way I mean
we shot this movie three years ago now
and it is still like still with me that
experience but that place has like a
[ __ ] magnet in it I went back to LA
for a week in the middle of shooting
that film and I was like what am I doing
here
yeah like because you you start to get
addicted to that science and you start
to just turn inward and get to know
yourself and actually to be honest with
you it that's the exact opposite of
sitting in your [ __ ] den watching
wrestling in right and killing your
slokas things are really hard -
everything's hard there I mean yeah yeah
but but it's also you're faced with
yourself and you have a small circle
around you and people say this about
making a movie but it really was like
that's the way it was snowing there when
you were up there huh a little bit yeah
here and there so it was actually there
was a blizzard when we started [ __ ]
polar bears they scare me Oh [ __ ] and
the other thing is the oh the the ocean
is frozen as you can see this right here
is we are we're just on the tundra a
little bit but right behind whoever that
is over there
oh that's emerald McDonald the lovely
baboo McDonald who plays Miranda in the
film who [ __ ] steals the baby she's
the heart of the movie it's [ __ ]
crazy never acted before never act of a
market and is [ __ ] doing this one
scene where we're watching her we're
like holy [ __ ]
she doesn't have to cry and this [ __ ]
scene but the [ __ ] is so real to her
actual experience she's related to the
real Miranda the person she's playing
that's so small the [ __ ] is all these
kids have these [ __ ] the same
experiences as the kids in the [ __ ]
that they're playing it's it's it's
trippy it's crazy and she was like
holding back the tears
in this thing where she's given Ben
Rusch Shepard some [ __ ] bench that's his
character and then she finishes the
[ __ ] take and and and I I have to
share this goes over into a corner and
starts crying because this [ __ ] is so
real to her during the take she's
choking back the tears like I'm not
gonna cry in this [ __ ] scene because
my character shouldn't be that upside
way of way more powerful give
veteran-owned Academy Award yeah what
[ __ ] actor what after do you know
that it's like oh I'm getting the
waterworks and I'm holding it back
there's no nurse in does it's been a
real person that's right but the tall
sister cries a real person tries not to
cry right yeah and it was it was I was
standing right there I was like this is
the [ __ ] craziest thing I've ever
seen then we the film why when they
watch me then I that's not an actor
that's a real person yeah when I'm on
sick when I'm on [ __ ] yeah when
you're doing you I'm you know like your
reality shows you have as a reality no
go right it's not it's one of those
thing you have notes like Undercover
Boss we're actually all short so a real
gym coach no yep you're nope yep nope
nope no no no yes no you're a cartoon
you're on guard to you cry all day long
yeah me I hold it back yeah uh-huh it's
always see it's right behind [ __ ] this
is an acting lesson no I'll let my
inches behind his face you guys are
gonna do this yeah you guys are gonna go
out there's a chance come are you guys
gonna get eaten by a farmer talking
through his nose hurry Meredith that's
good acting I eyes I can do too high
emerald goes and tells about the movie
that she had a little cry alright and it
was [ __ ] unbelievable I'm like she's
holding back the [ __ ] and I'm like give
her like what what's better than that
we're at the Toronto International Film
Festival right the film premieres yeah
and it did very well it's just such a
wonderful movie and and being in the
theatre with with an audience to see
that film surrounded by all those kids
and and you know much of the the crew
was was a pretty cool experience einer
just afterwards sayin Emily do you know
what you did like do you I was really
curious like are you aware of how
better she present wonder she doesn't
your and Paul Natalia better handle lamb
right there [ __ ] incredible Babu
Stewart amazing what better that she
doesn't know I mean who knows who knows
if she if she'll she'll ever I don't
know
there's Paul in the starting out that
guy that's my [ __ ] dude right there
that guy first day he goes I'm your
bodyguard I'm gonna take ya anyway
[ __ ] incredible actors [ __ ] try
their whole lives and you will try this
is why you are obsessively lifting
weights working out with someone like
Nick watching what you eat yeah
not having typhus no the night after
having some weed nope this because Brian
wants to be the first actor to live to
150 yeah so that he didn't have a
[ __ ] hope of achieving what these
kids do miss [ __ ] [ __ ] you broke you
[ __ ] you did [ __ ] you did [ __ ] you
oh hey hey [ __ ] Hey oh man you're
[ __ ] coward you're [ __ ] your class
sounds like [ __ ] fermented wool
reindeer we gotta stop eating rat and
red caribou oh so good though you get to
be a real coward let's go to some
current events by hey current events
current events that's Instagram account
alright no there was an Instagram
account that garnered a lot of attention
it was called the Sudan meal project and
they said that for every person who
reposts an image that they created that
basically says repost this and for every
repost we will donate a meal to a child
in Sudan for the crisis they found out
that this is actually a account made by
somebody just to garner more followers
for themselves because a couple of
people are like oh well what what other
companies do you work with to provide
these meals how are you getting
the money to the people in Sudan and
they started to find different diems
from that Instagram page where they're
basically saying oh I didn't know he's
gonna get this big and I was doing this
for followers please don't tell anybody
I'll give you a shout-out if you keep
your mouth shut
and yeah this is the post that went
viral for everyone listening
the Sudanese meal project says oh no no
the person writing says that's messed up
you're profiting off this whole
situation and Sudanese meal project says
I'm sorry I just wanted followers and I
thought I'd gain a lot off this please
don't tell anyone I beg I can shout you
out or anything and then the the person
writing them says you are wrong Wow
you're gonna see a lot more fraud like
this there's so many ways to take
advantage of people on the internet so
bad yeah and the currency now because
it's likes and followers this person is
doing it purely because then they wanted
to have followers and then switch it
over to who they yes like the end game
would be oh now it's just it's my
account I'm [ __ ] will and my account
has a [ __ ] ton of followers yes but then
everyone would know you're not thinking
two steps down the road to know that
you're it's hey you were just Sudanese
meal project and they're getting money
from it they were asking for money here
they were not asking for money they were
saying they were lying and saying that
they were working with a company who
would then donate money for every time
that post was reposted onto somebody's
Instagram story so they were doing it
just for followers and just for reposts
I'm a little more forgiving because they
didn't get money for it they were just
trying to be but this is the but this is
the currency they are real it's a shitty
thing it's a shitty thing to do and at
the end of the [ __ ] day you know the
kids aren't people aren't getting
[ __ ] well which I I'm not doing
anything about that currently either so
you know [ __ ] me right I give all right
let's go to the next one thank you
oh this is the Alex Jones one don't
thank the game yet so there is a case
going on with Alex Jones and the
families from the Sandy Hook shootings
and Alex Jones was forced to turn over
emails to the lawyers of the families
from Sandy Hook
within those emails those Sandy Hook
family lawyers found child pornography
on them and they're say Alex Jones went
on his show and he said that somebody
sent it to his email and that he never
opened it if he did he wouldn't have had
turned that over if he knew and so he
put out word that he would give anyone 1
million dollars for any information on
who might have sent it and he's just
doing his old spiel on your information
to Sudanese meal project then what
happened he's just waiting now he's
saying that it's not a threat to the
lawyers of the Sandy Hook victims but he
does think that they are colluding with
Democrats in order to get this case
interesting well million bucks is a
million bucks if he's claiming that he's
innocent
yeah apparently though nobody opened the
files yeah nobody okay I can believe
that there was something weird going on
do you want to hear yeah I'll give I
don't like the guy but when you call up
oh we'll protect you
we found the child porn I like women
with big giant baby I don't like kids
like you goddamn rapist heads in fact
like this you are gonna get it you child
molesters Oh gives you the Nu now we're
done right there I know what I know I
should believe it radio probably stolen
out I don't care you're trying to set me
up a child porn I'm gonna get your 1
million dollars 1 million dollars you
little gang member 1 million dollars to
put your head on a pike 1 million dollar
I'm gonna get your ass you understand me
now what is it I don't know you're not
gonna ever defeat Texas you sex it so
you get ready for that so where is he 1
million dollars you little yeah he not
on YouTube anymore he's got a play zone
plot for Partizan website okay Wow
[ __ ] crazy look III whatever whatever
that's about child pornography I'm sorry
I know we were on the radio how
fine child probably how did that get on
there that's what I want to know uh
nobody knows
apparently the email that had the child
porn on it was never opened by Alec
Jones or anybody on his team they just
turned over everything that they had oh
so it might have been a spam folder or
something good yeah there's that sounds
like a bunch of [ __ ] Alex Jones for what
he did to the kids but yeah yeah yeah
that whole Sandy Hook food fishy to me
when he apologized for that at some
point well he had he's being sued by a
very powerful law firm and they're not
they're going for blood yeah not for
[ __ ] so this law firm in Connecticut
does not compromise they they just they
go for that's it's scorched old news
are they from Connecticut yeah oh they
do not compromise the law firm from
Connecticut firm no I know a guy who
knows them and he was like dude dude
these guys squashed oh hey Brian what's
up it's your friend from near
Connecticut just want to let you know
about this law firm from Connecticut
what are they doing well currently they
have a lawsuit against Alex Jones these
guys do not compromise and it's three
years what do you want I'm just letting
you know I'm person that you know by the
Jimmy Burke's
nephew no this is the other guy calling
you huh you hear about Jimmy Burke's
nephews friends moms that sister's
boyfriend
no yeah he was having sex with Jimmy
with my with Jimmy Burke's nephews
cousins moms step-sister statuses Yeah
right and a dude came in he [ __ ] show
up the mountain killed him
it's good yeah
yeah [ __ ] Alex Jones well well well
Sean's got big problems he's got big
problems come after his supplemental let
sink but we they got to get to the
[ __ ] bottom of that and here's what
happens I mean you that's that's [ __ ]
heavy [ __ ] and he's saying 1 million
bucks million bucks is a million bucks
say sure I mean he seems to be
maintaining as is interest I hope they
get to the very bottom of it because
I'll be fascinated to know if it's just
spam [ __ ] I think it's everybody yeah I
think they're gonna find this is all
[ __ ] oh yeah
you know anyway I [ __ ] holy [ __ ] if not
holy [ __ ] that'll be a napkin hell of a
he's my age yeah he's 44 years old you
might be one year old it looks much
older yep Planet Fitness celebrates body
positivity with dad body sold you all
about it
yup so Planet Fitness commissioned a
company to do a research on what people
find attractive and what type of body
types they find attractive for their
Father's Day promotion and they're
basically marketing a new deal saying
come as you are but most women and
people in general find dad bods to be
more attractive than people who are
leaner that's [ __ ] yeah that's just
fun to say until you see a guy with a
great body and then you're like oh I got
a [ __ ] fat test I saw dude yesterday
I was driving and do that shirt off and
I I drove by and I went well I was so
gay because I went that body you forget
that some people have these insane
bodies I went what the [ __ ] he had 9 did
he have smooth hairless skin but he had
like this like it looked like a suit of
armor and it was just he was just an
athlete him with like kind of that bent
smile just walking and I was like what
the [ __ ] man I suck look man here's
what's up I just admitted to you that
I'm laying on my [ __ ] back watching
WWE wrestling get easy well you know
eaten [ __ ] yeah a bunch of food and
chefs very long do you like you sure
yeah look am I am I my my lovely
girlfriend there right what a beautiful
beautiful girls to she's helping me with
the food yeah and it finds you
attractive and yeah I know a lot of very
beautiful women that have found you
attractive so do I my friend okay take
it easy
I'm just saying women are not nuts about
ABS on everybody that that that may be
in a pack that may mean I'm saying I'm
speaking honestly as a guy who's like
I'd like to be in different shape okay
right okay that we know that here's
what's up the dad bod thing is just to
make us feel good about having a mostly
sedentary lifestyle I am look I've been
an athlete in my life and I've done
all sorts of working out and this and
that lifting weights and [ __ ] yeah Muay
Thai and everything so if they look out
look at the extension on my knee it Dave
and I see all the way that's all the way
I can kick all the way up above my head
ready baby so I'm speaking as that guy
we're just given ourselves props for
having the bodies that most people have
it's right and it's about accepting or
whatever yeah that's [ __ ] great
you want to put a [ __ ] label on it go
right the [ __ ] ahead it's a free [ __ ]
country but it's not what people prefer
let's go back to talking about people
who walked across a [ __ ] land bridge
when the [ __ ] water was low enough
because the ice had melted and they're
[ __ ] running down caribou and [ __ ] on
their feet so those people sure mostly
would have incredible [ __ ] bodies and
the standard back then would be look at
this [ __ ] incredible have you ever
seen like you know historical depictions
of you know different well you know what
I'll go to God go to someone like Brady
Quinn shirtless thousands of years ago
dude know whatever you wanna do it chin
don't do it I know you're there what you
know thousands of years ago when the
lifestyle was you know run down a
[ __ ] saber-toothed tiger then your
body would have looked a whole lot
different different they were all looked
you know like me naked
it's a [ __ ] sight it looks like
someone took a [ __ ] polar bear and
[ __ ] strapped its shoulders down to a
weight bench and then put three thousand
pounds on the back well we wrapped it 50
times I don't know well that's what my
body looks like I don't have skin I have
hide okay and my [ __ ] chest is trying
to get out of it yeah me naked is a
[ __ ] sight that most will never
forget for only Goodreads because you
look like a naked polar bear yup
somebody shaved a polar bear and you've
never seen what that looks like sure
that sure the legs I've got thick
[ __ ] legs you know my ass is just
narrow enough to fit no sequence here
dick cuz a polar bear's dick is on the
inside of his
no you got a pug not bring up Brady
Quinn bring up all the merger let's see
let's see that to my body okay I feel
that we're looking at polar bear look at
this kid is shirtless yeah alright one
of these guys any of these athletes yeah
there you go now now I think girls would
like that in order to have more than
yeah you know a dad Bartram
yeah okay yeah that's what I mean yeah
some guys [ __ ] hits yeah my acne
teacher said men have tits and asked to
when they're in jail maybe that guy's
for arms yeah I met him and I remember
looking at him I was like he's such a
[ __ ] athlete quarterback for me is
just it's just a great-looking kid in
this day all battling but just a beast
six four and here you go what do you do
what do you do I use that he was the
comments at the Comedy Store I went well
that's a pro athlete who's also happens
to look like a [ __ ] J Crew model one
night we're having dinner at scopa and
Brendan chubbs dear friend Tim Tebow
came yeah and Brendan did reprimand you
afterwards for the way that you turned
into a suitor a gay man for Tim Souter
you had your hand on his shoulder and
you just wouldn't let go you're like
yeah and you're talking abut you're like
out feeling them yeah and it was time to
oceans
I brought my hands look at that that's a
that's an athlete look at the neck yeah
look at them but again that's not a dead
body what I'm trying to say is he put a
hole in syndrome everybody if given a
choice would have that body over even
that that's him that's him like out of
shape three years after retiring how to
shape best-looking guy at the pool that
day yeah
now please type in polar bear penis nope
now that Brian this is fine tonight
polar bear penis it was hard to find
pull the Brett pingguo okay now let's
those yellow penises scout skinny and
long and yellow that is yeah that's was
the middle one like it's - the middle
that's you're sure it's not as long as
the ones on the top to the bottom but it
has a nice even girth the entire time
and as you notice not no [ __ ] head it
looks just like on tape arm mine my
penis looks like a no it looks like a
[ __ ] tube of
Wilson tennis balls now but bright pink
with two with a little snout
anodized lacking a flathead a real flat
head flat as a board
yeah yep and I can suction it to the
mirror if I have like a full-length
mirror and it's always a little wet I'll
lick it stay kind then I go because it
has snout touch and I can pick up the
mirror yep like a drag of the product
before can you and that Stannis no dick
has olfactory senses what yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
all of its all of its senses y'all right
it can smell you can feed it peanuts
right yeah I like toss peanuts up into
my mouth with my dick just like an
elephant well yeah and yeah and days
when I get dexterity all the way up to
my mouth and I give my dick Mike my pig
snout [ __ ] a kiss
you got your dick mix now yeah it's got
a [ __ ] two holes it's got two holes like
a pig snow cheese it's pissing much you
got to see you got a piece it now do I
absolutely have an expert event please
like someone saw the [ __ ] snow
actress bella thorne she actually
started out as a Disney Channel star
she's now this is all legal so it's fine
she is over the age but she was getting
blackmailed for having her nude somebody
hacked into her phone and a piece of
[ __ ] yeah they got a hold of some videos
and some photos of her naked and she
ended up actually just posting it up on
Twitter herself with a note saying that
she couldn't sleep at night she was
crying all day I agree with that and she
wanted to basically be in control of
what happens to her so she posted her
news on to Instagram along with the text
messages from the guy who was
blackmailing that [ __ ]
and the guy please tell me if a person
there in the process she did make a note
saying that the FBI is on their way to
get him they do have a nice guy I don't
like public shaming yeah this guy should
be [ __ ] public if he's 14 is different
he's a [ __ ] little [ __ ] needs to
be slapped around if he's a grown man
I you gotta be and and if you I know
Bella thorns really I don't know she is
don't look at the pictures yeah don't
look at them don't you do it man I know
you want to just don't do it out of out
of respect for her privacy foot real man
here's the other hand be a gentleman
don't be a [ __ ] I
don't even look you know I like naked
ladies right but I'll tell you what I
now that you say that and I'm not even
joking I think we're at a point in in
our understanding of the Internet and
how it works that it barely even matters
what's more interesting is these I mean
it is I'm sure there's people who are
fans of hers or whatever like guys that
are familiar with her I'm not and I'm
like oh like I saw a clip on the
Internet where Whoopi Goldberg was
talking about it I guess she's pretty
but she's also like super young and [ __ ]
and it's like I also kind of feel like
we're at this point where it's like a
that part doesn't even matter and that's
what makes her pulling this move
actually kind of interesting and I think
very justified yeah because it's like
whatever whatever there's you know why
whatever because there's so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the Internet yeah in about ten
years all of our texts maybe even now
the technology may be possible all of
our [ __ ] will be searchable all of it I
know so
yikes yeah but it's gonna be hey who you
want you are Oh Bryan Callen really is
I'd be able to do is go hug tight I type
here yikes what may Brian's phone will
be the Apple yikes all it does is send
yay but my time we won't know it's real
cuz with artificial intelligence you can
that's actually a really good point now
it'll be like it the information will be
like [ __ ] I'll just see like what oh
yeah okay that was me right but but
we're getting to a point where say you
were saying like oh movies came out
people really gave a [ __ ] back in the
day I remember I didn't give a [ __ ]
about Batman yeah I knew it was coming
out in 1989 cuz I'm gonna shut up about
it on TV and it was like Jack
Nicholson's and Batman oh it's cool Wow
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] I remember where I was
nowadays there's so much stuff it's like
the nobody would have known about this
well that's the other things nobody
would have known about this if she
didn't pull that move but I still
support what she's doing because it's
her [ __ ] choice and she's completely
just pulling the rug out from underneath
yeah and getting the person who's trying
to blackmail her it's like you'll [ __ ]
you yeah I'm a a pretty well whatever
this isn't this doesn't matter but I'm
pretty woman that people you think
people would want to look at nudes of me
I'm here shot to you he goes to did that
to all those women like and I'm earned I
was like don't don't look at those
pictures yeah don't do it man
turn your back because also is you're
not this I couldn't it's not she doesn't
want you to see it
so you that in her window you peeping
tom [ __ ] well it's the same
reason that we give the middle finger
from within the confines of our car but
we wouldn't do it walk in a because you
don't want to get your yeah you're being
a coward but you're also a callous
against common decency don't [ __ ] do
it and also if you want to think about
it like what is that what is the actual
you know logical reason for that is
because you're voting with your clicks
your set all you're doing is you're
saying yeah I support [ __ ] like this
happening when when you look at
someone's support it showed me you're
saying yeah yeah I'm sorry it's I know
you I've known you a long time no no but
finish what you're saying is actually
important so I was piggyback and I were
upset no all I'm saying is oh do we do
that [ __ ] podcasting it was the only
ten minutes long so you can kind of do
some fun things with that but he likes
to anyway so it's sometimes it's hard
just cuz I got off on this no I know you
and when you think you're like our Bob I
know most people like I'm gonna hold
that I wouldn't even listening we are
saying it okay so what I was saying is
this you're voting with your clicks so
the logical thing is if you don't if you
don't want to live in a [ __ ] world
where people like this can can you know
can profit from [ __ ] that they have
you know that they should not be able to
profit from because it is [ __ ] up
regardless of your moral stance I think
you'd probably think this is [ __ ] up
if you think it's the Wild West where
you can just do whatever the [ __ ] then
that's gonna happen to you so we all
agree that all that's [ __ ] up you're
the logical thing to do is to not click
on it because you are voting with your
clicks you're showing this [ __ ]
that it's good if you if you click on it
but anyway yeah so in South Korea they
got a hold of some nudes of a pop star
and this guy tried to sell them and you
can hear the [ __ ]
magazine guy like saying listen you
[ __ ] you know he was so mad and like I
think the entire this magazine posted
some of these pictures and all of Korea
like the entire population of South
Korea including the fans stopped buying
the magazine you know silent protest and
that magazine had to fold its rights the
way you do that [ __ ] in South Korea they
were like [ __ ] you guys we don't do this
to work to be like wall it was so it was
so they're very conservative you know
but there was it was so against there
sort of get you're not done do it don't
date don't do it you're it's good to
it's almost a form of digital rape or
something I don't know yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah I mean anything
that'll make I mean don't do it and
she's [ __ ] how we do 22 okay she's 22
young for anybody and also they have to
[ __ ] deal with that [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] traumatic it is like digital
rock cuz then after that happens I could
[ __ ] you up for life so thank you
[ __ ] cool like hardcore and badass
enough to go F [ __ ] I'm gonna take
the [ __ ] teeth right after yeah you
know what you're doing actually when you
look at those pictures in a way and
especially I'm sorry to say this but
you're taking something that doesn't
belong to you you're you're you're
stealing something from that person she
doesn't want you to see it she doesn't
want you to see those pictures were
taken for somebody she likes or she
wants to share with somebody that's a
that's an intimate private moment you're
taking something that doesn't belong to
you Brian I agree with you 100% and I'd
like to piggyback that go hey be more of
a hunter when you're up on top of your
lady yeah at night yeah and you're
sweating and you got pumping and you're
making her feel good yeah with your
polar bear pigs now yep and someone
comes charging into your home P red do
you harm
yeah you're a hunter you're [ __ ] your
lady right and now you're all charged up
or she's [ __ ] you maybe you're on
your side maybe you're on your side in
the Equality move your inequality like
an evil sign you're a real sort of bent
or you're a real bad a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
yourself easy now she's on top watch it
I will you're getting [ __ ]
hey day
buh-bye hey I actually ran event place
when that's happened drink some of your
piss take a [ __ ] dedicate it to your
mommy and beat their [ __ ] ass okay
hunter that's don't looking go get up on
that woman that loves you preach [ __ ]
preach with that Poehler that jaundice
yellow polar bear few more if you gotta
have those got and then leave a [ __ ]
Rhino [ __ ] in your wake along the path
for barefooted hotel employees to come
around the corner with a [ __ ] rifle
and see that that poor dude chokes out
leave when you're done with that guy
leave a mess like those hyenas did with
that kudu yeah it's my high you know
precision that's good dude
thanks much [ __ ] gay I got more
current events I go one more just one
more
yeah yeah all right that's also what you
sound like when I'm [ __ ] taking
taking what's mine
so this Instagram couple right here wow
they got a GoFundMe or they open a
GoFundMe account to help pay for their
trip so that they can show their fans
you know the world and how adventurous
they are great it's it's a gift for
their fans
oh I got you he'll oh he looks well like
situated those tattoos on his face I
mean this guy really wants he's got to
figure it out
he's got it figured out and he's
apparently they're lovers travelers
dream changes by the way I'd like to do
that I was like my face within because
he's got deep messages on his face oh
man that's freedom and his girlfriend is
stunning yeah what because a girl wants
to be seen with a guy like that he's a
good-looking guy I disagree
good-looking kid I don't know what's
going on yeah I do that's called pure
narcissism they're super vain he huh but
that's pure narcissism and their fans
yeah
but she's great she's delicious she's
she's a beautiful Anika
how many times you to the universe and
journey in a sentence up several times a
day even while ordering at Starbucks and
she's got him beat by like two pounds
he's a little sweet he's got a long neck
he's actually 5-1 but he has six foot
that's a man giraffe yeah you [ __ ]
man giraffe
I'd like to scrub off all of his tattoos
might to cut his head off gasoline and a
brick and and then steal his girl fastly
a brick and then steal his girlfriend
steal his girlfriend physically and let
her lay a while guys you know what I'm
gonna do yeah and and I would like for
him to watch me not make love to be made
love to buy his adorable girlfriend
while I'm laying on my back in a Thai
food in haagen-dazs coma stone to [ __ ]
and I'm still gonna watch NXT wrestling
yeah and slow gases are coming out of
your [ __ ]
shout out to Kyle O'Reilly and the
undisputed heir that's listen well this
has been um look what he wrote that's
what they wrote for their eyes shield
fund me account we could write a long
text about mental health or global
warming a dude shut up we could tell you
about following your dreams yeah or how
important stepping out of your comfort
zone is we this is just all useless
platitudes we could tell you how
beautiful travelling is and its benefits
or the fact that most news don't match
reality but we're gonna show you less
talking more action truly one of the
most unbelievable pitches we then he
goes on he says we want to take you all
on this huge adventure a celebration of
life as we ride freely across mountains
by the sea and through the
Metropolitan's the mountain will show
the beauty of this of this planet and
its inhabitants but also the ugliness
but we cannot do this on our own we need
you and they said a source said that how
much his mom was the one that actually
paid for them but she's now unable to
afford it
they're both unemployed yes the point is
that they he has some deep messages look
within this freedom
some other [ __ ] on his [ __ ] face
yeah congratulations on your choice and
it was enough to land that thank you and
that [ __ ] day a couple of narcissists
too want to go on vacation I'm gonna
follow her hey guy if actually [ __ ] it
let's use the podcast what's his name
and what's their name another beautiful
day official do they each have do they
each have their own Instagram we're
gonna we're gonna do a call to action
here
do they have their own they must they're
narcissists yes II know no they only
have the one the couple one that so it
looks like they might have their own but
let's see how I figure that a cat and
Elena um yeah no there's no way down let
me see there uh see if they're tagged in
that one that says go fund me would you
mind huh see if they're tagged in that
no so happy with them are they tagged
now no clicking yet cuz here's what I
was gonna suggest everyone on the
internet within the sound of our voice
right now should follow her and not him
let's put a cavern between the two of
them let's break these [ __ ] up
let's make her single everyone if we can
do it yeah okay go - what's this
definitely don't follow this another
another underscore beauty underscore day
underscore official beautiful another
underscore beautiful on his court day
day honest for official yeah that's and
that's shocking that an Instagram and
all be that long so far too long
keep scrolling down I want to see all of
it there's no you're not a narcissist at
all yeah he's all about himself so you
can go there please please fighter in
the kid listeners go there do not follow
them but find out please find out and
share with other listeners and and
hopefully chin you could maybe share
what they find if there's tags it's
probably like the clothes yeah whose cat
was I don't know that's salt insulting
its cat it's a different oh we might be
getting close
no no no I think all the people that are
targeted or there's someone who did that
that's not the studio is okay but please
try to find out if they have their own
Instagram accounts if they do follow her
not him only follow her not him
let's get her way up there look he's
only got forty three thousand followers
so yeah so and if you are following him
unfollow him and then delete urines had
a lot of face tattoos going on here
congrats on your choices will Congrats
on the choice of coming here and trying
to do stand-up I'm not trying come see
me in Tempe at the Tempe improv this
weekend starting actually in a mall
Thursday Friday Saturday Spokane
Washington be in Spokane Washington this
the 11th and the 12th at I'm not sure
what the name of the venue is but does
it smoke the smoke in there you go and
you're there till the 13th so learn how
to read yep and we'll probably open for
me in Tempe this weekend okay you know
it's funny we do that David Greco thing
that's right it has a lot of fun San
Francisco cops came in 20 come see a lot
of fun San Francisco cobs July 1920 get
your [ __ ] tickets lucky to Brendan
Brennan's gonna be in Calgary this
weekend the 20th the 21 and 22 go see
him at yuk-yuks he'll be at the Brea
improv I was gonna be there looks like
I'm gonna be in a wedding hall I know
June 27 28 29 I'm sorry I can't be there
but he will have some very funny people
there Cincinnati Ohio July 12 and 13
he'll be there and and I will probably
bring Will Sasso onstage for one of my
shows probably Tempe this weekend I
can't be there but and just everything
take a long old fashioned car antenna
and and beat him with it while he's just
gets teased tied to the ground and he
makes weird hyena noise you're gonna
need two of those antennas to shove them
up each of my [ __ ] piss holes because
I got to at the end of my older really
hurt alright kids that I think that's it
I think we'll thanks for coming on me
thanks for having me okay hey thanks man
you the spider the kid we're out